ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show I am Tim Dylan we are back
here in the studio coming at you from
Hollywood California drove in today from
an undisclosed location from a bunker
where I will be returning to until
everything calms down when and if I
don't know that LA or New York City is
going to be my home base in six months
or a year I don't know I don't know I
might just go and find a place to go and
put a microphone there and that might be
that might be the reality I don't know
what's gonna happen
things'll I'm sure return to some level
of you know and we've got July 4th that
we got the Republican convention we got
we got a summer of rolling riots
probably just a boiling hot summer of
Sam that's on its way you know so yeah I
know that it's privileged that I don't
want to be burned alive
I get it I know it's privileged I don't
want to take a rubber bullet to the face
I don't want to get maced you know I get
it I understand you know I want to
continue to draw breath I know that to
some of you that's a wildly
inappropriate position but that's where
I'm at
that's my political ideology I'd like to
stay alive for a little while that's my
stance on everything oh what's that are
you coming down on life watch watch the
we're gonna play for you
Bill DeBlasio getting introduced I'd
like a protest and this is the funniest
thing ever and I love like politicians
are trying to
saying like you know Obama sang and it
was a powerful moment but like you know
remember he was in the church and he
sang Amazing Grace but now nobody
everything's past singing and de
Blasio's wife like after he's just booed
de Blasio's wife gets up and she starts
to sing and it's great listen to this
and first lady should pray pray again
again again we say respect we serve
respects a we respect respect respect
[Music]
nothing bombing bombing she thought that
was gonna be a good opener yeah she's
like power to the people
she thought everybody liked him unison
was gonna be like power to the people
and everybody's like we are sick of
hearing you [ __ ] sing sick of
politicians getting out in front of us
and singing power to the people and you
could tell like as soon as it didn't
land she was like oh boy it's the same
thing at Comic deals with when you go
out on stage and you thought something
that you really think it's brilliant
like you think something's really gonna
hit and then it doesn't and you're like
okay okay I got a retool we got a real
tough crowd out there real tough crowd
Bill DeBlasio is a tremendously
unpopular guy what's great now is that a
lot of these politicians are hated by
both the extremes on the left and the
right there's just they're just hated by
everybody pretty much you know cuz if
the Blasio doesn't abolish the police
and replace them with social workers
which is what people on Twitter want to
do he's a Nazi
right and on the other side if the
Blasio doesn't call in the National
Guard and shoot everybody in the face
and as a black lives matter shirt he's a
[ __ ] on the other side so you have to
incredibly reasonable groups of people
right now in the public square people
that think that all police should be
replaced by so what is social work let's
be very honest about what social work is
it is usually a white woman who shows up
at your house and she sits down with you
for an hour and they talk about how
[ __ ] you are
that's social work so
they want police replaced by those
people
okay bunch of Carens out there with
clipboards being like oh my god where
did he burn you with the cigarette it's
not good you don't have to take that and
on the other side you have people that
you know want the military to come come
down the street with tanks and just
start yeah I mean you gotta you gotta
see what some of these people want you
know people on Facebook or just like put
these animals down you know my anti
Facebook is like just put him down her
last post was a recipe for a cake that
she liked you know [ __ ] you scroll
down a little bit she's like just put
him down god damn it
so those are the two extremes you have
now and in the middle is JPMorgan Chase
going hey you know I had a great tweet
people liked where it's like this will
be a commercial where you will see a guy
throw a brick and then it'll be caught
by somebody who works at JPMorgan and
it'll go like this it'll be like you
know you'll you'll you'll you'll see the
brick fly and the brick lands and then
the person who catches it stacks it on
top of more bricks and then you see
those bricks become a house and it goes
JP Morgan Chase wants to build a better
world starting with you inquire about
our loan programs now they're gonna have
the black lives matter mortgage soon JP
Morgan Chase don't worry
city bank's could have the BLM mortgage
low interest rate interest only balloon
subprime mortgage they're gonna try to
sling to people in the inner cities
we're gonna call it the Equality
mortgage that's what they're gonna do
come today and get your Equality loan
that's what corporate America is just
trying to figure out how do we profit
off things burning down there's
something funny about that
idea because there's people right now in
boardrooms going how how do we market
broken glass and teargas how do we find
the angle that makes people want to buy
and consume what about this makes people
want more of something how do we target
the demo okay so the city is on fire and
there's we're inching towards the civil
war in that climate how do we tell
people now more than ever it's important
to get a home equity line of credit
because we feel that to really fight
equality you should get a home equity
line of credit but you know that's their
gig that's their job I get it you know
these are not corporations don't have
soules you know they don't have a
conscience isn't a morality they're just
trying to figure out how to make a buck
and this is not an easy time to make a
buck
they say man easy time to hand out
samples at Trader Joe's have you tried
the hump have you tried - have you tried
the sun-dried tomato have you hi how are
you are you coming from the
demonstration do you need water for your
eyes again get them some water I think
there's something wrong with here weird
so where did the bullet hit you have you
tried the sun-dried tomato it's very
similar to the traditional hummus I
don't like sun-dried tomatoes because
we're usually overpowering but this it's
just kissed by it
it's kissed by the sun dried tomato try
it try it put your mask on try it put
your mask on okay you're a vector of
disease as well as well as a hero as
well as a freedom fighter you are vector
of disease put the mask on how do you
sell [ __ ] we got pandemics we got a
civil war
how do you just get out there and
prospect right now very tough very tough
to go out there and try to you know
try to get the people to see things your
way but these corporations are trying
God love them they're trying they got a
right I mean we got to do business I
know you know a lot of people don't want
to hear that but we got eventually get
back to business I'm starting to think
the lockdown was a mistake sorry I'm
sorry to think the three months of
telling people to not see any other
people and to spend 23 hours a day
online might have been an issue that
might not have been the way to do it it
was a social experiment it was a fun
social because what it was is I'm not
minimizing the 50 years of racism wealth
inequality state-sponsored terrorism
none of that is being minimized here but
what was the cherry on top of that
sundae was was telling people that they
couldn't earn money and they had to lock
themselves inside and not see or touch
any other human beings it was it was a
real acceleration of a lot of the things
that I had previously mentioned in the
sentence which I'm not ignoring at all
by the way I don't think that like the
lockdown was up the reason for this but
it certainly didn't affect people's
psyche in a positive way can we say that
can we agree to that that we didn't come
out of this stronger than before you
know remember when the lock that started
people were like we're gonna come out of
it stronger we're gonna come out of it
and then just the sound of explosions
and gunshots you know how's that work
out for anybody did we come out of it
stronger I don't think so
does it seem does it seem like we came
out of it stronger and it is
hypocritical it is hypocritical to tell
a bunch of people that came out to
protest the fact that they had lost
their health insurance and their jobs
it is hypocritical to say you're killing
people you're killing old people and
immunocompromised people and then to
just completely greenlight mass
demonstrations in in a pandemic that
supposedly is just killing people and
overwhelming healthcare systems it is
hypocritical to call one group of people
terrorists and sand and just give the
green light to the other group of people
and all the celebrities and the people
that live in you know very wealthy gated
enclaves behind gates and they live in
mansions are all like you have [ __ ]
the lockdown and then they turn around
and they're like you get out there and
you [ __ ] March your March and it's
like wait a minute
people's heads start spinning you know
doesn't mean the protests aren't valid
or that the cops aren't out of [ __ ]
control but it means that like you know
there's got to be some logical
consistency where you go wait a minute
what happened to Corona vine will they
just coronavirus came back by the way
George Floyd died of corona virus that's
what they're saying they're saying you
had coronavirus Geoff st. George Florida
had cove at 19 which I predicted on the
Shelf course of course there yes and
they want to just go through a few other
things I'm the twin towers fell from
coronavirus the mortgage crisis in a way
the financial crisis was due largely to
a wet market in Wuhan China most of the
people that had been shot in the last
year by police unarmed black people all
had kovat 19 in their system in fact
many of the epstein victims that nobody
has found we've done a private
examination on many of them many of them
died from coven 19 don't worry about it
not you know God this Kova nineteen's
powerful it's just killing everybody
everything the government doesn't want
to admit to coronavirus corona I bet
Epstein had covered 19 can can we get an
autopsy of Epstein I guarantee you he
did not die from his fix
I am almost positive he died from
coronavirus can we find that out please
I guarantee it
how sad I bet Michael Hastings died of
coronavirus and that's why he couldn't
control his car when it you know went
into that tree in the middle of
Hollywood I bet it was Cove at 90 it's
all covered 19 it's all coronavirus baby
all kur it's like 1010 wins all news all
the time you know the United States
government all covered 19 all the time
and it's like you think it might have
had to do with the the police the boot
on the guy's neck for what cash in a
fake check he was he was he they I mean
they should barely respond to cashing a
fake check who cares
start responding to violent crime if
you're not gonna prosecute white-collar
crime when it's done by these [ __ ] on
Wall Street let [ __ ] a few people
have a little fun in Minnesota cash a
fake jack you know who gives a [ __ ] the
guy's trying to cash a fake $20 check if
that's even the truth and they're
treating him like he's a sama bin Laden
and they're sending in a [ __ ] crack
team of people to subdue the guy I said
yeah it says here so now we got these
four officers watch when they old I've
covered 19 what George Floyd is given
the four officers coronavirus and they
are all dead now they all face charges I
bit the side of my mouth and it's been
horrible for the last four days I don't
know what to do I've been I've been
brushing my teeth and I've been gargling
with solution and some [ __ ] I guess
I'll take some ibuprofen I don't know
what to do because when you bite the
side of your mouth it gets inflamed and
then you continue to bite it and it just
becomes a real nightmare
I'm not equated that with the other
problems people are going through right
now and I don't want you to think I am
but it
not fun on May 25th Floyd visited cop
foods grocery store in Minneapolis well
that's cop foods is not the name of a
place you feel I mean if you can't use a
fake first of all who's still accepting
oh it's a fake bill I'm sorry not saying
shack vic-20 fig $20 bill who cares if I
accident from someone else if you get
changed and you don't realize it you
know of course you can and even if you
didn't it's not a death sentence Floyd
visited Cup Foods grocery store
Minneapolis to buy a pack of cigarettes
the store employee believes the bill
used to be counterfeit reported it to
the police do they get in trouble if
they take counterfeit money I think so
yeah okay the store owner Mike abbu Miya
la la that's his name Mike abbu Miya
told NBC he was not at work the day of
the incident but that his employees told
him that Floyd initially came into the
store with a man and a woman the man
tried to use what an employee suspect it
was a fake bill which the employee
caught and gave it back to the man abbu
Miya La Jolla Leigh said Ford would turn
to the store about 10 minutes later and
tried to use a suspicious $20 bill to
make it purchase the employee didn't
realize at first but when they did they
followed protocol and called the police
and then what happen in the Coulter
9-1-1 the employee told the operator
that he has floyd for the cigarettes
back but he doesn't want to do that the
employee claimed Floyd was awfully drunk
and not in control of himself
Floyd was near the store sitting in a
car with two other people when the
police arrived they were responding to a
report of a forgery in progress which by
the way I mean could anything seem less
dire than a forgery in progress you know
like there's somebody on a counterfeit
bill gab take them down it's not a
counterfeit $20 bill right do you know
the havoc he could cause in society
with a fake 20 he might go to Carl's jr.
the police departments had a physical
altercation between the officers and
Floyd unfolded after Floyd got out of
the car when the officers approached the
car one of them Thomas Lane began
speaking with Floyd he pulled his gun
out and pointed it at mr. Floyd's open
window lovey go right for the gun this
is policing in America right for the gun
and I listened man when I was in
Manhattan Beach and that cop was like
dude Oh little [ __ ] Sora you could see
that a lot of these police not all of
them there are good police but there are
also good people in Isis and I'm not
saying that the police are Isis but
there's good everybody that's like not
an argument that's not an art there's
good people and Isis
there's a guy in Isis whose [ __ ]
nephew got blown up all he was playing
soccer and he just wants revenge and it
doesn't make him a bad person you know
what I mean I refuse to buy into the
binary that's created by the [ __ ]
media on our government I don't you know
it is what it is there's good people you
know in most organizations truly you
know he pulled his gun out and pointed
it at mr. Floyd's open window but these
are these the cops have got to calm down
here we got to calm down everybody all
the time is ready to pull the gun out
put the gun in someone's face and this
and this is why these lock downs again
you hand over a bunch of power to the
federal government you tell people to
become rats and keep they call the cops
on each other the government of
California encourage people to rat on
people that were its social distancing
and then where do you think all this
[ __ ] comes from the cell phone videos
taping people [ __ ] look at this
person's doing something wrong and I've
got it on my phone
we we've creating a nation of rats who
are calling the cops they're cop callers
and rats and they're filming people
doing things in their private [ __ ]
life and this was requested by the mayor
of Los Angeles okay
the prosecutors say Lane put the gun
away once Floyd put his hands on the
steering wheel but put his hands down
we've all watched this video by the way
Floyd is not resisting at all
there is really no resistance in the
video of the video that I saw
Floyd then actively resisted being
handcuffed the statement reads when the
officers tried to bring Floyd to their
cruiser he stiffened up fell to the
ground and told the officers he was
claustrophobic the report states so kill
him I mean I don't understand so put
your boot on his neck um the police
account has come in contact with at
least one witness yeah
so then Shelvin arrived arrived later
who's shoving show there Derek shout
Chauvin Derek Chauvin is the guy who's
being charged with second-degree murder
trove it arrived on the scene shortly
after to help the police officers and
getting Floyd into the police cruiser
the report said shove and pulled Floyd
out of the vehicle causing him to fall
to the ground he laid on the ground face
down and still handcuffed
that's when onlookers began to record
cell phone video so the guys on the
ground and he's in handcuffs and somehow
he is still a threat worthy of putting
your boot on his neck cutting his hair
supply off and then the guy died I mean
this it's inhuman to defend this
behavior by the police by the way it's
it's inhuman my stomach hurts my neck
hurts please please I can't breathe okay
this is what he's calling out he's also
calling out for his mother okay I mean
the guy knows he's about to die and the
cops stand there and watch a guy get
murdered in the street for for buying a
pack of cigarettes with a counterfeit
$20 bill you know so you know I think
that looting and violence
I think violence is like a virus that
just is gonna spread and you're not
going to be able to control it or
contain it and a lot of the
practitioners of it are people that
don't want a more equal and just society
they want to take
advantage of an already bad situation
right I've said that and I think
violence also leads to more state
violence right that's just what happens
but I'm completely aware of why the
anger has risen to the point of violence
and you can be too if you watch that
video if you watch that video you can
understand why people have had enough
and they've gotten to the point where
they're just basically like hey [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
you know I mean that and if you if you
if you don't have that reaction when you
watch that video there's something wrong
with you if you don't automatically feel
like what the [ __ ] you know folks is you
adapt to the changing world we're all
gonna be buying more stuff online you
know if you're an e-commerce seller are
you ready to meet the demands of our new
delivery culture because nobody can go
outside now you know whether it's
coronavirus rubber bullets tear gas you
know I mean it's just different now you
know climate change feels fun compared
to what else is going on but if you
really want to buy [ __ ] or even more
importantly sell it it's you're a seller
be ready with shipstation why
shipstation when you're selling online
getting a lot of orders out fast can be
tough how do you keep track of who gets
what with shipping carrier should you
use are you hitting the best rates are
you getting the best rates
that's why you need shipstation dot-com
this is a fast easy affordable way to
manage and ship your orders a few clicks
and you'll be managing your orders print
the out labels and getting your products
to happy customers ship station makes it
easy okay it's easy to do you're gonna
need to start an online business if
you're broke and you've got a talent
sketching drawing knitting crocheting
painting whatever it is if you're a
craftsman it's make things woodworking
whatever you [ __ ] do you make a table
anything you need to ship ship station
can help you
they help online sellers of any size kit
orders get out quickly so you can be big
or small it doesn't matter no matter
what you're selling Amazon Etsy your own
website ship station brings all orders
into one simple
interface making them really easy to
manage from any device even your cell
phone so if you're trying to start an
e-commerce business which is how a lot
of people are making money if you're
actually trying to do it you say to
yourself like I got something I can do
something there's a way for me to ship
something then this is the way to do it
this is the easiest way to do this
especially now okay it's the number one
choice of online sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
available and right now the Tim Dylan
show listeners could try shipstation
free for 60 days when you use the code
Tim dylan TI MDI ll o n that's ship
station shi PST a tion dot-com today
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Tim Dylan do
not forget the code you can try it free
make ship happen fun fun little thing
they did there but the reality is if you
are in the business or you're in the
market of selling things online and
you're gonna have some type of you know
some type of business what you're gonna
have to do is you're gonna have to
figure out a way to keep it organized
you'll get over your head very quickly
I've had friends try to do this and they
fail because they get in over their head
very quickly and they're unable to
manage their orders and they're unable
to make sure everything is executed
properly and and that's what you want to
do you want to cut cost this is not
expensive it's an inexpensive service
and it scales up depending on how much
you're doing if you're not doing a lot
it won't scale up but if you're doing a
lot more it'll scale up but you can
scale it down anytime so ok it's not you
know it's a monthly rate it's not per
shipment so it's where people that want
to start doing business want to take
that side hustle or hobby that you have
and make it into something real a lot of
people have lost money right now and a
lot of people have talents you can but
rich people still want to buy [ __ ] they
still want to buy things make a little
fee make a birdfeeder
they still want to buy things kit make a
riot glasses for them like the glasses
where they can see the riots and you
know and there's a rubber bulletproof
and start making covert masks
no make big trendy get into it you know
fun gun holsters I don't words hand it
out there but little craft Seba shitty
things and you sell them it's nice
people buy them you know maybe maybe a
really good carpenter and you wanted to
start you know putting that stuff out
maybe you maybe you independently
produced a book and you want to ship
books who knows who cares
you just got to ship something ship it
ship it now sell something to someone
start selling your items in your home
start selling them get rid of them you
know you don't have to do like you know
the people in Philippines sell the kids
you can just sell items you got a nice
old toaster sell add there's somebody
with a mid-century modern home that's
gonna want an old orange toaster and
maybe you have it not everyone in the
Philippines is doing that it's just you
read articles it is what it is the point
is this this is the reality of what the
world is you have to earn a little bit
of money okay
sell it ship station comment do the code
Tim Dillon TI m TI ll o n folks you can
do this you can start bringing in a
little extra income walk around your
house con what don't I need put it in a
box you know you could you could go and
catch it and sell it online make a lot
of money go to yard sales go buy that
should sell it online
maybe you open up like a weird little
vintage I I sell vintage kitchen shed
you you go you hunt for trash my mother
used to drive around the neighborhood in
a big van putting garbage in her van she
never did anything with it she should
have but they didn't have ship station
okay but those are the types of things
you can hunt for cool [ __ ] and then
resell it at a markup price or you could
make stuff and resell it doesn't matter
what you do you know make kovat masks
you know would Confederate flag on them
or something you know did show that
racist can go out and guys take it
seriously I don't know I'm just telling
you these are the groups out there that
maybe underserved the racists who are
still taking kovat seriously is probably
an underserved market it's probably not
a huge overlap but hey I'm sure their
buyers shipstation dot-com check it out
earn extra money god I hate bad Cologne
it's the worst thing in the world and I
love Hawthorne Hawthorne helps elevate
your scent because they design it for
you it's an entire line of personalized
colognes and grooming products for guys
smelling good is important the Hawthorne
smells really really good and they make
the process of finding and buying your
signature scent easy you take a quiz as
Hawthorne it takes about two minutes and
it tells you exactly which products
match your style in order to come up
with a perfect kid for you they'll ask
all the usual questions about your skin
type and how often you wash your hair
but they'll also tell your products
where you work and what you do for fun
then they'll match your scent to your
lifestyle hey I am AI loot i riot great
no problem he'll figure it out
also hey I'm a racist cop that's far and
they have it all
none of the gross chemicals you get in
the store blood stuff and now they offer
personalized skin care face cleanser and
face lotion tailored to your specific
needs Hawthorne is totally risk-free
free shipping and free returns get the
complete kit and never run out again
okay I'm telling you so much better than
buying a one-size of all cologne from a
department store that now you can't
because it's burned down anyway online
is a future folks it's got I've gotten a
face cleanser deodorant shampoo body
wash lotion they're all pretty cool they
ask you a few questions you guys figure
it out they have a cool you know they
have a cool way to match whatever since
you want like I wanted my lotion to be
more burro light to smell like a
Marlboro light and they've done that for
me and that's great it's very important
body wash some people might want hot dog
water some people might want lavender
it's up to you
you make the choice you want to get out
there and get [ __ ] you got to work
with your own pheromones your own you
know you got a you got a tailor a tailor
fit it fit it tailor it up make it your
own make your smell nice but also you
unique people like oh my god what is
that smells great what is
smarter light is someone smoking no it's
my lotion from Hawthorne
that's Hawthorne dot C o H aw th o RN e
dot co and use my code Tim to get 10%
off your purchase Hawthorne dot CE o try
it today it was a bad idea after 9/11 to
give every cop in America the idea that
they were part of the Homeland Security
Department it was a bad idea to convince
everybody that had any type of job that
required security that they were you
know essential and that they were you
know they they weren't able to be
questioned and that they were the the
final say on every matter you know
whether it's a I mean you walk around
Manhattan and they're there a doorman
that have that attitude I mean there are
you know transit cops that have that
attitude you know everybody seems to
have the attitude that they are the only
thing standing between you know you know
the George Floyd's [ __ ] $20 bill is
the only thing standing between you know
the collapse of the financial system you
know they're treating this guy like he's
the biggest threat ever and they
wouldn't have done it to a white guy
they just really wouldn't have you know
I you know that's just the way it is
it's I'm telling you they would not have
done it to a white guy that way you know
the white guy would have had to behave
in a manner that was so dangerous you
know school shooters get walked out of
schools where they just shot nine people
in the face white school shooters get
walked out of school like they're
petting their heads
the cops are petting their heads as they
walk out to singing them silent night
holy night they pray with the school
shooter the cops take the school
streeter out y'all get on their knees
start praying with them now let us pray
now your your you're a bad boy you've
been a bad boy and you might have to do
four years in prison I mean these kids
you shot you know 12 people in the face
while they were eating lunch
eating sloppy joes a kid gets a bullet
in the head the cops the cops walk the
guy out there's not a scratch on them
well 10 the school shooters always
surrender it's like well I bet that's
not true and I also bet that there's a
better way to handle somebody who's
resisting than to put a boot on their
neck for nine minutes until they die by
the way there's just true it's just you
know I mean I don't know what to tell
you I've had interactions with cops that
have gone the wrong way yeah I mean I
think I famously talked about the one
where they thought I [ __ ] myself
I mean that got me out of it excited
satin steak sauce cops pulled me over
they thought it was smoking pot I was in
the passenger seat of a car I got out
and I just had brown all over my pants
because it was Smith and Wollensky steak
sauce and all the cops we're taking cell
phone videos of me because they thought
I [ __ ] myself by the way they thought
I'd [ __ ] myself because I was afraid of
them they thought and they they
delighted in that and they wanted to
show all their [ __ ] loser cop friends
look we terrified a guy so much he [ __ ]
himself
first of all hey hey pigs out there I
[ __ ] myself often and then there's
nothing to do with you by the way okay
okay my system just evacuates when need
be has nothing to do with you so and not
all cops are pigs but there's some bad
ones out there you know some real real
ruffians and and they were standing
there take his cell phone cameras at me
because they wanted to show other people
like this guy [ __ ] himself because he
was so terrified of us because he was
sitting in the passenger seat of a car
and maybe was smoking a joint in the
passenger seat of a car okay and that's
you know one of them one of the many
interactions that I've had to a police
but I was a criminal like all the
interactions I've had with cops and and
I was rarely arrested and I would get
pulled over a cop would go license
registration and insurance
and I would literally look at I might be
smoking a but I got I don't have any of
that I don't have any of that sir I
don't what they got mr. Dillon your
license has been suspended about 20
times you got yeah yeah it's about that
isn't it
they're like you shouldn't be driving
them I know I know I gotta go to work
you know and that's that's you know and
then once or twice he put me job a lot
of cops look alright hey listen you got
your buddy in the car let him drive or a
cop will go listen don't be around this
area anymore just get out of here I'm
not gonna bring in but hey don't come
back here you know how many black people
get that chance
how many black people get the chance
where they go hey buddy I know you're
driving an uninsured vehicle with no
license your license has actually been
suspended 20 times and is suspended
currently but just get out of here you
knucklehead
you silly goose you're a silly goose so
I get it I get it you know I mean I knew
a kid there's a kid I used to do comedy
with in Long Island for nine cops fought
like nine cops you know like the judge
said to him who sent him the judge was
like listen it's clear that you're a
good guy somebody said to the guy it's
clear you're a good dude you know my
friend was in a courtroom like watching
this happened the judge is like
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
problems you know everybody you know and
and then the guy is like does zero jail
time he fought a cops didn't get shot to
get into zero jail time I read about a
football team at Greenwich Connecticut
it was like a fight the football team
this was years ago there's maybe in
Darien Connecticut at football team
fighting in Connecticut whatever they
break in to the dudes
house it's like a party they break in
which is a home invasion somebody lets
them in and yeah there you go fight
between New Canaan and God no no no go
back so one day Blake break into the
guy's house
one kid holds him down the other kid
like beats the [ __ ] out of him
okay and then when the judge is sensing
this guy he's like hey man you got a
bright future it's in the [ __ ] I
followed the case a little bit it's like
the judge is sensing the guy and the
judge goes listen it pains me to have to
give you any time you got a bright
future all you did was break into this
kid's house and beat the [ __ ] out of him
in his home you got a bright can you
imagine a judge would stand up to a
black guy who did that
broke into a house started beating the
[ __ ] out of a white kid and [ __ ] New
Canaan Connecticut the judge gonna every
Bay you know I mean it's it's different
it doesn't mean it's all race it doesn't
mean the cops don't abuse white people
but I live in Long Island the home of
dirtbag white people I mean did you see
the Long Island pro and get up the
Merrick Long Island response to a
peaceful black lives matter protest they
were terrified that Merrick Road would
be taken up by protesters and they
wouldn't be able to go out and get a
sandwich watch this watch this community
members here in Merrick and surrounding
towns adamantly opposed to Nassau police
trying to figure out a way to allow
protesters to walk up
people I've got kids there they're like
let's teach our kids how to be racist
and apathetic to every all of society's
problems
let's bring the it's like a young kid
there is a young kid there and [ __ ]
slides like to put like water sandals
kids in water shirt to get kids probably
in the backyard in the [ __ ] sprinkler
and the parents like John get in the car
there's blacks in our town we're gonna
go get them
get in the car mom I want to play with
my friends get in the car right now
people want to change things in this
country and we're gonna stop them we're
gonna stop them they want to walk down
the street with signs and exercise their
First Amendment right their right to
speak freely in their the right to
assemble and protest they and we got to
show them that that [ __ ] don't fly in
Long Island mom I just kind of want to
hang out with Jack's coming over no
we're going to the protest tell all your
friends you go to a race riot with your
mother we're going to a race riot with
your mother now you'll see your friends
there's enough time in the day for
friends today's race riot with mom
get him the hell out of here yo Giacomo
do some get him out of here they're
protesting police brutality get him out
of here I love that there are kids there
I mean how sick are you
you bring the kid you know people I
guess you know people are just like
listen this is a historic moment son by
the way everybody who's saying maybe
they didn't have a babysitter long
island people leave their kids home for
all kinds of reasons alone all the time
so let's cut it out
that kid was old enough to be left home
alone for a little while it wasn't like
a young kid that you had the parent it
was like a kid who clearly could have
stayed home but the parents thought it
was a good idea to just go let's just
bring yeah let's just bring a race right
it's bringing in a peaceful protest that
we're trying to turn into a race riot
because we got 40 white people out there
screaming at them with bandanas by the
way now everybody looks like a blood or
a [ __ ] mm like all these white people
are wearing bandannas to protect from
covin so they all have just read been
that they look like it's like the Hells
Angels looks like a biker gang heading
up the street these masks are terrifying
folks I hope they [ __ ] work is it
terrifying as [ __ ] I just love that just
a bunch of fat people standing outside
America I mean look good yeah you get
out of here
don't clog up the street what are you
doing what's your problem the cops are
cops get a beat on you with batons
what's the problem if you don't want to
get hit don't go outside like you got to
hear like people's did people in Long
Island at defend these police shootings
the the logical jumps they have to go
through a crane like yeah what are you
outside in a park you're gonna get hit
this was like pre-pandemic by the way
they were just trying to justify
anything like
the deal if a cops beaten you you're in
the wrong I that's it if a cop has got
his gun in your face you've done
something wrong I know that because my
brother Larry is a cop and Larry tells
me these people help to no good that's
why we got to beat him with sticks in
the street even if to the handcuffed
even after they pose no threat to
everybody Ari was upset that the you
know his wife made him redo the kitchen
they took out all kinds of money all
kinds of loans you know Kitsch was not
being done so you know Larry goes out
there with his baton and find somebody
to make pay for that you know the Long
Island the Long Island listen to this we
surrounded the protesters because we
protect all of the probate hold on there
was the police commissioner yeah dude
you never quote for any of the Long
Island people just go west go west
that's good hey go west
you're east no we agree with everything
the police are doing we don't care we
like the military like the Blue Angels
in fact we think the Blue Angels should
go and drop bombs on the protests that's
where big deal yeah why don't you drop
bombs at a protest
well guess do you know how many people
in this country would really not care
they love it they would love it if the
government just started bombing the
protests they would think it was great
they would watch it the same way they
watched the bombings in Syria just just
eating the bread stick just chewing on a
breadstick drinking a Coors Light
watching bombs drop like it's an episode
of [ __ ] you know Ozark they don't care
and it's not to say that the looting and
the riding you gotta have order I get it
100% you got to do something you got it
you got to prevent criminal activity and
behavior and people from like taking
advantage of what should be protest but
the hedges article makes a lot of sense
he says listen language of the state is
violence that's the only language the
state speaks is why they don't use
reason they don't use rationality they
use violence use intimidation that's
what they do so when you're living in a
society where the only language people
have learned their entire life is
violence and they respond with violence
again it is not right and I don't think
it leads anywhere good but when you look
at it you go yeah this is why you're
seeing this now you know and there's got
to be there's got to be more leadership
and then on the side of people that are
protesting and there's got to be demands
and there's got to be reform and there
has to be thing and without those things
it's just an unending journey into chaos
nobody wants that I think it ultimately
benefits Trump if there's chaos usually
Republicans win in years when when crime
rates go up where there's chaos for
there's incidents like this but maybe
you know I don't know I mean you know
Trump is not handled this well general
mattis is now going out and criticizing
Trump saying he's violating the
Constitution they want him out you know
they want him out it's it's not
sustainable to have this guy is the
president I mean I know many of you were
like no but well how are the kids gonna
get freed what about the kids and the
tunnels yeah okay but let's deal in in
reality and facts is not that
sustainable like however you feel about
Trump you have to realize that he's
maybe I had like a negative effect on
the psyche of the country you have to
grant that right like the tweeting and
just the emotional terrorism of every
day of like you know I mean this guy as
the country's Bernie he's tweeting about
how great the stock market's doing
because I think the markets headed back
up next year is gonna be a good one what
I mean the guy is completely he's just
tweeting law-and-order fake news fake
news there's civil war broken out and
certain parts of the country the guys
tweeting fake news maddis had a scathing
description of trump's walk to a
historic nearby church money and then
Pelosi grows and grabs the Bible by the
way hello she then goes he grabs the
Bible she goes hey this city it did it
this guy who they all hate goes and
grabs the Bible they know it's a cheap
stunt and instead of calling it out they
go like this they go I'm gonna do it
hold on I'm gonna do it let me grab the
Bible this is a woman who gave a tour of
her freezer on night three of the
quarantine when everyone had lost their
job
she gave a tour of the different kinds
of gelato she had in her freezer by the
way you know I mean this is a woman
who's like we like the chocolate I like
chocolate and then you know it's great
we take we take all the gelato we take
all the after we're done with it'll NT
we go down to the hospital we let the
women use the containers as masks the
nurses so it's very nice this episode of
the Tim Dylan show is brought to you by
sheath underwear sheath underwear is
great it's great as a bathing suit too
by the way it's like doubles as a
bathing suit it's amazing sheath
underwear what makes it different is
simple she's underwear has a special two
pouch compartment that keeps your twig
and berries from sticking your inner
thigh it's gonna be a hot summer full of
bullets and gas so they're not not not
even farting I mean tear gas chemicals
so that's it that's the idea it's
brilliant okay this thing keeps your
dick from sticking to the side of your
lug you slagged lug sheath underwear is
made from a super comfortable blend of
modal and spandex it stretches as you
move it keeps you cool and dry no
bulging pinching or sagging
she's underwear cradles you drunk like a
mama gorilla holding her precious
newborn baby you know how blade is half
human and half vampire so he gets the
best of both worlds well she disliked
Todd only the combination of boxer
briefs and jockstrap all the powers none
of their weaknesses the idea for sheath
came from its founder a US Army soldier
Robert Patton during his second tour in
Iraq
so if you see a National Guard guy say
thank you
thank you for this underwear I'm wearing
if it works in the Sun bless the deserts
of Iraq you know it'll work wherever you
live
it's a veteran owned indie company whose
founder is a fan of the show it's easy
I wear this they send it to me free I
wear it it's my new underwear it's great
it is good especially if you sweat it's
gonna be a brutal summer for many
reasons it's either you get 20% off your
first order okay it's 100% money-back
guarantee and everybody loves it sheath
underwear calm ass he8 eh underwear
dot-com promote code Tim T I am you get
20% off your first order if you get your
first order you'll keep getting it
because I just keep wearing it now I'm
just not buying any underwear they'd
send it to me and I appreciate it I
would buy it too if I had to but I don't
because they're a sponsor but I'm using
it you know that's the reality so
support the show support them get sheath
underwear it supports you especially if
you do something where you're sweating a
lot if you're an athlete if you're out
there it's important thing dude they
send me the raid kind of your buds and I
absolutely love them okay they're half
the price of any other wireless earbuds
on the market they sound just as amazing
as other top audio brands everybody
loses ear buds then they try to replace
some of their $7000 the newest model the
everyday e25 earbuds are the best ones
yet with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more based in a
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit rate cons Wireless
here but they're so comfortable perfect
for conference calls or binging podcasts
unlike some of the other wireless
options rake on earbuds are both stylish
and discreet with no dangling wires or
stems to distract anyone during video
calls guys even if you have other
earbuds buy these and wait to lose the
other ones cuz when you lose the other
ones you'll use these you'll never use
any ones again
it's founded by Ray J Snoop Dogg cardi B
Melissa Etheridge brandi jr. smith are
obsessed with r and cons everybody uses
them i use them it's easy to get them
rake on Comm if you go to buy rake on B
uyr a YCL ENCOM slash tim t IM
that's by rake on comm slash tim you get
15% off rake on wireless earbuds i mean
these are really they're there if
as good if not better than then the
Apple ones and there's so much less
money so you know you also you need
wireless earbuds they can't have the
wire if you have the wah if you have the
wire n you might as well be homeless
walking in somewhere right now with a
wire attached when your buddies
basically saying hi I'm a homeless
person and I'm diseased hello you gotta
have a wireless here but that is 100%
what you have to do there is absolutely
no way around it you've got to have a
wireless earbud in your ear and the
Apple ones are too [ __ ] expensive and
Apple's a call to care as you know you
lose them there's just you know the
insurance doesn't cover anything it's
just it's all a problem over there you
know rake on wireless earbuds so buy
rake on comm /ti em they're bananas but
we got to calm it down we got to rein it
in that seems to be because it's just
gonna get worse it just gonna spiral out
of control you know I'm not trying to
get a rubber bullet in the face I'm not
trying to get dead to your gasps in the
face here you know I mean it just seems
like these things are exponentially the
the violence is next-level cops are
getting shot and stabbed protesters I
mean cops are in certain areas of
country handling is very poorly and
they're firing rubber bullets at like
peaceful protesters and they are
shooting tear gas at peaceful protests
it's it's just it's a death spiral is
what it is so unless somebody stops it
and then there are people that are on
Twitter cheering it for it to continue
they're like God burn it down yeah and
they're on Twitter and I'm like you're
next you're gonna burn down that there
was a comic I wants his name he tweeted
I swear to god this is this is when
these virtuous signaling people they
trip over their own feet a comic cussed
me and my wife went to go look at a
house in Connecticut the next-door
neighbor had two confederate flags in
the window we didn't even get out we
just drove home
you're looking at a house in Connecticut
huh and you're not the enemy you don't
think you're gonna be the enemy and why
why are you going to Connecticut why are
you leaving the city has something
happened so you do have to realize you
destroyed no matter how woke you want to
seem no matter how you're you're the
enemy you will become the enemy because
violence doesn't have a rationale you
know the point of torch for Jane Mayer
said it when we were torturing people
remember that remember that eight years
ago Jane Mayer she was either quoting
somebody or she said that she might have
been quoting someone she goes the point
of torture is always torture okay and
that's really the point of violence is
violence like it has its own rationale
and it spreads and it's not logical and
what happens is you basically just you
know you become an animal you began and
the type of state-sanctioned violence
that we see is very organized but it's
no less animalistic it's you know no
less brutal so when you're just going
out there and you're hurting innocent
people and you are destroying small
businesses some of the moment I - and
you're just you know going out there and
using violence it will lead to more
violence and then we're just again we're
living in and to me I don't understand
why so many people are fetishizing that
idea the idea of just a cot and I think
it's because they don't know anything
about violence and they're like live in
a video game and they don't have any
respect for it and they think they can
direct it Slyke a force they think they
can direct they think like well if we
unleash this violence we can direct it
to the means that we find appropriate we
think that this violence can be used to
and it's like but that's not the way it
works that's not the way it works they
say I mean look at any of these videos
of of these these white people like
cheering on the riots and then bricks
come through their windows now like
we're on your side
no we're good where are the good ones
and it's like no no no you you can't put
the genie back in the bar
it's out chaos is chaos and if you want
to live in that world and a lot of the
people that are like abolish the police
will not do well in a Mad Max scenario
because they're immunocompromised and
they're 97 pounds okay where are you
gonna get your green hair die without a
civil society okay so I don't think this
ends again with a fat woman with green
hair is the president ant if it takes
over wouldn't it be funny yeah and Tifa
takes over how hilarious would that be
like somehow they like maybe
everything's a lie and our military is
does suck yeah like they can't do
anything we just hear how great they are
but let's say they just aren't that
great obviously we know that they'll
just use weaponry from right guys but
let's say none of that works and somehow
and tufa succeeds because that the
Conservatives are pretending anthem
feels like it couldn't and Tefal will
what do you want them running the
country it would just be hilarious if
like they you know the country was now
being run by just gangly you know mainly
white pale malnourished vitamin D
deficient like guys that didn't get the
Montreal Comedy Festival like like
failed comics and slam poets with purple
hair are now running the country that
would be great the Fox News has to come
back on the air and be like in a
stunning in a really surprising
development antiphon has defeated what
was the United States military they are
now running the country and so far has
fired the military and they are now
replacing it with a security force of
mainly theater kids who grew embittered
at the lack of opportunity in the
entertainment business and became
volatile and radical whilst living with
roommates in their late 30s they will
now be the security force of the country
angry fill
Theater kids are now running around i'ma
be amazing like instead of the Blue
Angels instead of the flyover over the
superball just eight you just like a
bunch of antiphon just runs through and
everyone like everything crowds like I
guess hope I guess they're they're the
runt they're running it now okay well
alright USA is just a bunch of like
malnourished kids USA just black
backpacks on yeah people like you you
can take your masks off you run
everything now they're like we like the
masks they have acne like we have adult
acne we're not gonna take off the mask
you know but that's the way people talk
about anta feel like it's like it's like
they're like they're on their way to you
know they're gonna defeat the the
corporate state it doesn't and I don't
agree with anything ant if a does by the
way for the most part I think some of
what they say is decent and I don't
really care like you know none of it end
see here's the thing it's like you could
find an example of somebody that Antipas
like thrown an egg out who you hate
right I [ __ ] that guy they threw a
negative but we live in a country where
people should be able to say what the
[ __ ] they want so no you can't use
violence to stop people from talking you
can't well the New York Times publishers
are not bad by the way the same people
that think that they can live in a world
without police cannot handle when the
New York Times publishes an op-ed from a
senator
who says we've got to bring the military
in so instead of debating that they go
you know this is we the New York Times
should be shut down there should be a
coup everyone should be fired I can't
believe they'd print that opinion but
you're gonna you're gonna somehow Howie
so how are you gonna live in the world
without any police you can't handle an
article can't handle Jordan Peterson and
yet somehow you think you're gonna be
able to live in a world without any
order at all just chaos and Anarchy
that's a fetish you know a Turkey's a
fetish of losers really it's people that
are convinced that they will somehow
either be powerful or align themselves
with the powerful people once society's
fallen even though they've been unable
to do that thus far they've been unable
to do that thus far but they think that
somehow if there are no police that rich
people won't just go hire Blackwater
military types to patrol wealthy areas
and we'll have more problems probably
less accountability you know they just
they just somehow think that and then or
some of them are just nihilist to the
point where they go who cares
burn it down I mean Oscar the cat many
of you know is someone who was a
nihilist I mean Oscar first of all and
this is very suspect and strange two
days ago Oscar joined the National Guard
he's never expressed interest in joining
the military before he joined the
National Guard okay okay this is
incredibly disappointing okay but a day
before that he was he was handing out
bricks to protesters so he just wants to
watch it burn there's a lot of people
out there that just want to watch it
burn and this is what I mean listen so
this is where we are this is where we
are on what day is it today Thursday
it's Thursday this is coming out
Thursday June 4 that's coming out Sunday
super proud of everyone from Long Island
proud he handled it you guys really
killed it you knocked it out of the park
you brought your kids out to see what
you're all about yelling at people that
have to want to peacefully protest I
like that that's good good for you Long
Island just keep being Long Island you
know and every year it gets a little
worse less affordable more of them get
pushed down every year more and more
people start you know shooting up opioid
crisis gets worse every year
you know um because so much of what that
community is based on is fear and hatred
which turns out is not exactly the best
way it's not the best organizing
principle of society utter illogical
fear and hatred that's what Long Island
is everybody's climbing in your window
ms-13 trying to kill you everybody's
trying to kill you everybody on a road
is trying to cut you off too trying to
get somewhere faster than you
everybody's trying to take your money
trying to take that house you inherited
fear and hatred as soon as your fear you
like well I gotta I gotta hate someone
so I just like that they were being you
know exactly who they are perfect and
the cops got to pretend that they're
like neutral Long Island cops gay yes I
know Jimmy I know chill shoot'em hey you
got a gun
Tommy just shoot him in the head Jimmy
they're high school students who cares
you know what I school students can do
if they want put a bullet in the back of
her hand
that's antic antiphon they're trying to
take over the delis what's gonna happen
when antiphon controls the delis then
what you're gonna eat vegan [ __ ] you're
going to get a bacon egg and cheese and
there's gonna be some transgender making
you eat vegan
no thank you I will he processed food
and I will die on my couch watching
Tucker Carlson I'm the only rational
really to be honest as much as I've
predicted and as much as I've been
correct about is there a reason I am
kind of not made a leader not really not
really
I should kind of emerge from this as
kind of a leader that kind of you know
because I get it I get both sides
I have friends are cops my friends into
protesters I have friends that are
rubber bullets I have friends that are
batons I have
to school with a tear gas canister whose
I still talk to all the time I have
friends that are looters I have friends
that are shards of glass I have friends
that are deep state CIA agitators I have
friends that are uh you know people that
work for Chinese intelligence Russian
intelligence okay I have friends that
are targets I get everywhere everybody's
coming from I can understand that I have
friends at are counterfeit bills and I
have friends at are cops that are
murderers so all across the board I just
think we can't live in a world of
unfocused rage you know cops need to be
taken down several pegs but I don't see
how smashing up a small business owned
by somebody who worked hard and has
never done anything like everyone call
the cops just protect property yeah but
freedom is owning property freedoms the
ability to not have to depend on the
government freedoms the ability to do
something without the approval of a
[ __ ] nameless faceless group of
bureaucrats you know so okay you know
what cops are protect property can we
have guns to protect property no well
then whose what we shouldn't have
private property well then what are we
gonna do well the government should just
dole out the land as they see fit to who
who's the government who's this magical
government that is somehow going to do
this appropriately you mean the same
government that backs the police so you
want them handing out the land and you
want them sticking a needle in your ass
in Walgreens you are Bill and Melinda
Gates putting a needle in your ass and
you want the government deciding where
you live and and how you live and you
want an den Ende but huh
try to follow logically where what is
is I don't get it I'm confused
and don't come like I don't read any of
the comment but like while you're typing
a seven paragraph response to me right
now about why private property is just a
tool of white supremacy realize no one's
reading it truly realize no one's
reading in what are those twelve thumbs
up gonna do for you go get a rubber
bullet to the face if you believe in
that why aren't you go and blow yourself
up I mean that's the thing in this
country we got a bunch of [ __ ] you
know here's the thing about the Middle
East they don't have a problem with
putting the vest on now I am NOT saying
to put I am NOT saying to put the vest
on and I don't mean the bulletproof vest
okay
and I'm not saying to put the vest on
but let's be very clear let's be very
clear about there's a difference
ain't nobody nan toughest got the vest
on you know what I mean
ain't nobody anthems got the vest on
I'm not saying to go out there wear a
suicide vest you know my sponsors would
probably be angry but Chris Hedges quote
great the idea that an tyfa which on the
spectrum of terrorist groups would rank
alongside the Boy Scouts is behind these
clashes is as ridiculous as the idea
that Russia is responsible fuel election
of trauma this desperate search for
explanations that absolve the ruling
elites so Susan Rice it was Obama's not
sac National Security Adviser blamed the
violence on foreign actors heading this
is right out of the Russia play but by
the way there will never be a problem in
this country that is not blamed on
Russia or covet nineteen it'll be Russia
and kovat nineteen are working together
Russia and Chinese bats are working
together Russian BOTS and Chinese bats
it's Russian BOTS and chinese bats
russian bots and chinese bats sorry we
shot you in the face - did you have a
boot on your neck
it's a chance a Chinese bot it's a
Chinese that or a Russian bot it wasn't
a boot on your neck
did your husk it foreclosed on it's a
Chinese bat bat bot bot bat that's what
it is just the government's just sitting
there on a pedophile island being like
soon they'll do that and just a lot of
Russian actors here on little st. James
there's just Russians and all the words
Russians running around and uh Jeffrey
Epstein was a Russian less watch there
was a rush in there all Russian they
died to Cove in nineteen everything over
nineteen is rot said everyone so Russia
has got over nineteen it's Chinese pot
it's not even real - Russian BOTS
Chinese bad it's a corona virus is a bad
flu high fatality rates a ventilator we
need a ventilator it's Russia launches a
ventilator China
stay safe out there
[Music]